the most useful shift in speaking is to
go from impress mode to express mode
everybody wants to impress while they're
speaking the pressure is the pressure to
be impressive and so we become
performative as if we're trying to add
value and we're trying to look a certain
way and so uh we enter impress mode and
that mode is really dangerous because
the the foundation of that mode is
Through The Eyes of other people success
is measured through something we can't
control mm so that's a very shaky
Foundation Express mode I really like
because Express is basically like what
you do with a therapist or what you do
with a close friend it's just like I'm
speaking as a vehicle to express my
thoughts to share what I have inside in
a in a mindset of I'm not being judged
right now and when we express our heart
comes through when our heart comes
through people tend to be more receptive
especially in the age of authenticity so
when we enter Express mode
we just speak for the sake of of sharing
an idea and we're not so worried about
how we look we're worried about am I
getting the thing inside across and the
fastest way that people can level up
their speaking is to enter this mode
because I find that like whoever
speaking from a mode of I just want to
express myself ends up being impressive
because you're surprised at how open and
honest and authentic they come across as
so most people go the traditional route
of I want to get good at speaking so
that I can be impressive and then I'll
feel safe enough in order to really let
my guards down and be a little bit
Messier I'm saying what if we reversed
the cycle what if we started giving
ourselves the safety and permission to
be a little bit Messier and our speaking
we'll actually get the goal of being
impressive as a side effect